brandon woodruff
yeah coming up with no decision his last
time out against the diamondbacks only
five innings
up six hits two runs one walk nine
strikeouts for brandon woodruff first
time
that he did not pick up a quality start
his last timeout since opening day that
was against minnesota so he's been
terrific making start number eight
against pittsburgh currently three and
two his record against the buckhold
woodruff ready opening pitch tonight a
swing of the fly ball
into shallow left playable and going to
be caught
in fair territory by willie adams one
pitch right now gotta love that it's a
brandon woodruff brian hayes is the
hitter
it's this one to the first base side
vogelback backs up the step feeds
woodrow for out number two one thing
that woody is going to have to contend
with is the fact that the pirates have
struck out the least of any team in the
national league they do not
strike out much and that's been a big
part of what woody's been able to do
he's eighth currently in strikeouts in
the national league they put it in play
don't hit many homers the fewest home
runs of any team in the big leagues
gregory polanco behind two and one and
this one a shot on one hot to jace
peterson
and it's a one two three inning
for brandon woodruff he needed eight
pitches to get through it chase de young
making his first appearance against
these brewers his third start as a
pirate only sitting 250 against him so
far the curve ball his best pitch throws
it about a quarter of the time
holding opponents to a 143 batting
average daniel vogelback there's a swing
of miss fastball a foot above the zone
and vogelback strikes out there's two
outs that was about as well as you could
pitch volkl back what dion did right
there yeah and two joe watch perez today
just the other day when he was catching
he was really doing a great job i think
he got it from will smith on the dodgers
side how fast he's moving his glove back
into the zone doesn't look like he's
jerky it's really smooth that first
[ __ ] and young just painted it but yeah
you're exactly right pitched him very
well had him guessing the right-handed
batter at 246 a dozen home runs
certainly capable offensively
there's a fly ball to center field
gamell coming in and gammel makes the
catch
garcia's retired to scoreless bottom of
the first for chase deyoung ben gammel
hitting at 184 without a home run he's
the pirates number five hitter tonight
then he drives one to right field ben
gamel clear the deck with a cannonball
his first home run of the season
his first home run is a bucko of course
and it comes in milwaukee and gives the
pirates a one-nothing lead how about
that
greetings for your old team uh and maybe
an old friend
in woodruff
right before he stepped in for the first
pitch kind of gave a little smile to
brandon woodruff a little nod in the
head and uh a big welcome here
always loved to do that against the
teammate
the former teammate and after the first
pitch breaking ball for a ball he knew
fastball was coming but hey look at that
right into our nachos jackie bradley jr
with the tying run at second base and
it's on one jackie to right that's down
omar narvaez is gonna be sent around
third here comes the play the plate not
in time we're tied
jackie bradley jr with a single to right
narvaez he outran it and we're tied
brandon woodruff squaring bunting it's a
good bun peterson gonna try and score de
young a late decision to throw to first
the brewers squeeze home a run
james peterson got a great jump on that
bunt by brandon woodruff it was a beauty
up along the first face side the brewers
have the lead
one-two pitch to the young there's
strike three called uh chase to young
first strike out of the game for brandon
woodruff one ball and one strike here on
frasier
and right into the glove of a leaping
urias at third for the second out of the
inning nice play by louisa
looks into polanco who's grounded his
second back in the first inning gregory
polanco
serves one into shallow left adam is out
still out makes the catch nice play they
got a great jump good angle right to the
baseball and made that one look easy not
an easy play for any shortstop
so athletic is william adamus check him
out i mean angling back perfectly
any false step right there he's not
going to make that catch well done a lot
of range right there from willie adamus
brandon woodruff says thanks
2-2 pitch
got that low strike at 99 miles an hour
second strikeout for brandon woodruff
he's retired seven in a row woodruff
dropped down that bunt brought home
jace peterson picked up the rbi
lines this ball to the center fielder
gamel
who will make the catch
and gamble
makes the play
four innings complete blanco coming into
tonight in the number three spot in
atlanta
and polanco sends one date to right oh
my
a large cup of coffee for el cafe to tie
the game that is his sixth and it's 2-2
and i don't know what it is with polanco
against woodruff but boy he gets some
good swings off of the big right-hander
coming in hitting 333 with a homer hit a
bullet his first time up almost blooped
one in his second time up and here it
gets a 3-2 heater elevated i got this
guy
the third diving stab
oh what a play by urias newman slams his
helmet down as he runs through the bag
at first ureas has become a highlight
reel no matter where you put him
defensively right now all you got to do
is listen to the fans at american family
field and you can tell number 22
stepping in with the bases loaded in a
tie game he'd like to drive one here if
he could get one to hit
ground ball towards the middle
robertson's in
uriz is in streaking to second with a
double as christian yelich brewers have
the lead he has been waiting to flash
the claws and finally he's able to do it
on their feet making noise 3-0 pitch and
he just walked him on four straight to
force in another run
the fourth walk of the enemy
runners will be moving
and that one's too high peterson waited
an extra beat just to make sure brewers
had another run to make it 6-2
and that's ball four
four straight walks have netted three
additional runs for milwaukee three into
the count here it is
and keep ryan hayes a no doubter clear
the deck with a cannonball in milwaukee
key brian hayes just crushed his third
wow that was impressive 7-4 ball game
now colin moran hits for the pitcher one
strike away from the victory for the
crew here comes hater struck him out
with his slider in the ball game is over
7-4 the brewers take down the pirates to
open up this home stand on the right
foot